[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
8 mars parole à bénédicte alliés qu in
adjointe au maire de guyancourt chargé
de la culture et du patrimoine elle nous
présentera les événements prévus tout le
long du mois de mars pour le temps des
femmes un mois spécial pour oeuvrer pour
l'égalité homme-femme parole aussi dans
cette émission au fille de robert
doisneau alors qu'une exposition a
débuté aujourd'hui à versailles sur une
partie de l'oeuvre du photographe
français l'exposition en question nous
permet de découvrir les années méconnu
de robert doisneau elle les années vogue
mais on débute donc cette émission avec
vos bénédicte alliés qu in bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes adjointe au maire à
guyancourt en charge notamment de la
culture et vous êtes donc en plateau
pour nous présenter la 7e édition du
temps des femmes un événement qui
s'étale sur un mois tout le long du mois
de mars à guyancourt expliquer d'où un
peu la génèse de ce de ceux de cet
événement le but évidemment c'est de
pouvoir à l'égalité hommes femmes à
travers tout un type d'événement c'est
ça c'est bien expliqué tout à fait alors
déjà je voulais vous remercier de
m'avoir reçu aujourd'hui avec pour cette
journée bien spéciale du 8 mars
bien sûr les 8 mars c'est tous les jours
que nous le célébrons à guyancourt c'est
à dire que c'est une préoccupation
quotidienne sur la ville de guyancourt
bien sûr tant sur les employés que sur
les droits sur le quotidien de ces voix
sont bien souvent habitués souvent les
mairies font des événements soient lus
mars soit pendant une semaine là c'est
tout le mois de mars donc ça a commencé
le 1er mars ça va se terminer le 31
c'est une vraie volonté de marquer un
mois ça veut dire que une semaine c'est
pas assez une journée c'est pas assez
pour parler au nom de l'égalité hommes
femmes
non non c'est vraiment une préoccupation
au quotidien et en effet notre
ce tuer c'est est de faire participer
l'ensemble des équipes et tout le monde
se mobilise pour ce temps des femmes
tant des femmes qui est une lumière
pendant tout le mois de mars de tous des
services qui se travaille dans cette
direction alors au programme pendant un
mois on a atelier d'écriture par exemple
un théâtre sport spectacle aussi est ce
que en multipliant les événements les
styles vous cherchez à vous intéresser à
parler à l'ensemble des guyancourt
poster qu'il faut pas être forcément un
amoureux du théâtre pour participer à
l'événement faut pas être un sportif de
haut niveau tout le monde peut y
participer tout à fait la diversité
c'est d'aller vraiment auprès des
habitants et même de les faire
participer et donc dans nos spectacles
bien sûr il y aura des spectacles tout à
fait traditionnelle et en effet je lui
conseille et je conseille à tout le
monde d'aller vers les équipements
culturels
mais il ya aussi des équipements dans
les quartiers il ya aussi surtout une
volonté de s'ouvrir vers les habitants
est en effet pendant ce mois via un
petit événement il ya trois événements
que je voudrais particulièrement
développée avec vous c'était idée
textile en effet on a deux artistes
femmes qui se veut une mère et sa fille
sylvie et marion bretons qui sont allés
à la rencontre des habitants mais
vraiment à la rencontre voilà donc
quelques images justement à l'écran la
salle à la rencontre des habitants et
qui font quoi qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
voir dans cette exposition idée textile
c'est en effet après une récupération de
jeep elles sont allées dans les
quartiers dans la maison de retraite
elles sont allés aussi au niveau des
jeunes pour pouvoir baptiser des liens
tissés alors bien sûr chacun s'est mis
au travail pour faire à 1
énorme
bandeau qui va qui est actuellement à la
mezzanine et qui permet de voir que
c'est un complément de son exposition de
leur exposition à elle dû donc pas là
une exposition d'artistes et de
guyancourt toit du coup c'est à fait
juste l'audace gym mars à l'hôtel de
l'huile c'est ça tu as fait avec un
vernissage je crois d'ailleurs que le 19
mars à 18h autres temps forts dont on
veut peut-être parler s'intéresser ses
vives et vaillante c'est samedi prochain
cette fois ci à la ferme de bel ébat
cette fois ci c'est des contes de la
musique et une soirée dédiée à l'égalité
homme femme expliquez nous un peu
comment on peut faire fonctionner ce
cocktail alors déjà c'est quand même un
exploit c'était habitants cd habite là
aussi si vous habitez les habitantes qui
vont au près de dinard tistes qui est
actuellement en résidence à guyancourt
et a donc au théâtre de bel ébat praliné
gay-para qui va ramasser les comptes
leur vie et puis à partir de ça va faire
un spectacle en effet elles sont vraies
et accompagné par la musique et donc ça
va être un moment surprise bien sûr
parce que j'ai pas vu la répétition je
ne sais pas quels sont les les comptes
qui ont été leurs histoires qui va être
représentée donc samedi ce sera le
samedi 11 mars à la ferme de bel ébat
aigles en cours moi j'ai lu compte sur
le site internet de la ville est ce que
ça veut dire que c'est aussi et surtout
pour les enfants
est ce que ces fonds publics non non
c'est tout public parce que en fait ses
comptes comptes conteuse
donc non il ya des contes pour les
enfants il ya des comptes c'est pour
tout public et l'égalité
nous sommes exactement exactement enfin
peut-être un dernier rendez vous auquel
on s'intéresse dimanche 19 mars des
initiations cette fois-ci et
démonstrations sportives sont prévues au
gymnase maurice becker est l'évènement
ça s'appelle sportez vous bien les
filles avec évidemment un jeu de mots
entendus sportez vous bien
bien sûr en fait l'idée c'est aussi
d'aller vers tous les publics
alors
là on est sûr peut-être plus sur la
jeunesse mais pourquoi pas tous les
publics
je précise quand même que les hommes
peuvent venir nous manifestions il n'y
avait pas de déflation c'est pas
desservis les abords et femmes c'est
l'égalité tout à fait et là ça permet de
découvrir tous les sports est en effet
est de dire aux jeunes filles qu'ils
peuvent faire du rugby part exacte et la
paix grand clément qui avait de la
pétanque à peu faire du football c'est
par les adapter aux hommes c'est
important de le dire donc tout le
service des sports s'est mobilisé les
associations parce que je pense que
quand on fait un événement comme ça
c'est aussi grâce aux associations du
territoire de notre ville en effet il ya
plein d'autres choses il ya plein de
choses dans notre programme et c'est
vrai qu'on voit
j'ai parlé d'un petit peu du théâtre
mais aussi à voir avec en directions
d'école des parents en direction de la
batterie un concert spécifique ya plein
de choses qu'on voit le programme qu'on
peut retrouver d'ailleurs sur le site
internet de la mairie on voit ici le
programme et expliquer nos juste une
dernière question que ce soit ces rendez
vous sportifs ou les autres événements
prévus jusqu'au 31 mars
est-ce que la cible prioritaire de ce
mois là est ce que ce sont aussi les
jeunes générations on en parlait est ce
que c'est à travers eux que ça parce
cette problématique de l'égalité hommes
femmes est ce que c'est eux qui peuvent
en gros tout faire changer en france ou
continuer de faire changer en tout cas
c'est à dire chargé continuer de faire
changer je pense qu'il faut faut pas les
oublier bien sûr c'est très important à
la jeunesse c'est important et ils sont
en train de préparer un petit film
j'espère qu'il va très très vite passée
dans dans les réseaux déjà et puis après
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de voir
aussi nous public
merci bénédicte alliés comme d'être venu
en plateau on rappelle l'adresse
internet pour avoir plus d'informations
sur le temps des femmes
www.villedebram.fr merci à jour beaucoup
on poursuit ce 7,8 les invités avec une
exposition qui vient de débuter à
versailles une exposition autour des
années voc d'un des photographes
français les plus connus
robert doisneau l'artiste qui est mort
en 1994 a travaillé pendant trois ans
reporter à mondain pour le magazine
og l'exposition a été imaginé par ses
deux filles découvrez tout de suite
leurs interviews par camille l'envers
avec des images de patrick jacques de
dixmude
nous sommes à l'espace richaud de
versailles où débute une exposition
consacrée à robert doisneau et plus
précisément à ces années vogue et pour
en savoir plus nous sommes en présence
de ses deux filles à anet doisneau et
francine deroudille bonjour à toutes les
deux bonjour alors je viens d'évoquer
rapidement les années vogue
si vous pourriez précisé un petit peu
plus cette période dans la vie de votre
père à quoi ce qu'elle correspond
c'était d'abord des 49 à 52 ans un signe
un contrat avec le journal drogue
on lui demandait de faire des sujets sur
la vie mondaine à paris où vous élargir
un peu le sujet mais c'était surtout à
cette époque les mariages chic dans la
vie mondaine ya plein et puis il ya
aussi la vie culturelle
c'est une percée on est dans l'après
guerre c'est à dire qu'à une reprise de
la vie culturelle formidable en france
et des jeunes artistes qui s'appelle
bernard buffet jeanne moreau qui est à
la comédie française michel galabru qui
vient de sortir du conservatoire et on
lui demande d'aller photographier tous
tous ces gens là et il est très heureux
de le faire parce que ils se sont très
bien compagnie des artistes peut-être
mieux en compagnie des duchesses et de
comtesses qui marient leurs enfants ça
fait partie de tous de toutes les
archives maintenant et c'est pour ça que
c'était intéressant de sortir ses
photographies qui sont moins connus
alors justement d'où vous avez vous
sorti comment est ce que vous avez
trouvé toutes ces photos graphiste dans
son atelier c'est ça comment ça s'est
passé
vous savez c'était un photographe
professionnel et c'était quelqu'un qui
archive est parfaitement ces documents
et donc il y avait déjà les négatifs et
est parfaitement classé numérotée des
planches de contact orange et
thématiquement donc il y avait une
grande thématique mondanités une grande
thématique mode une grande thématique
théâtre cinéma etc
donc quand on a ressorti toutes les
parutions de vogue
on est allé rechercher
plus généralement dans l'ensemble des
négatifs y en a 4 450 milles en tout
donc sur les archives vraiment
heureusement parfaitement ordonnée et
combien sont exposés ici pour trouver 73
ouais je pensais d'accord elle aura ce
que pouvaient expliquer un petit peu
nous parler du lien qu'il entretenait
avec et devant de charles roux
rédactrice en chef de l'époque de du
magazine vogue
c'était important justement c'est la
relation qu'il entretenait avec moi ça a
été essentielle pour tout ce travail ils
sont restés amis vraiment jusqu'à la fin
des du temps mais elle était elle aussi
venait de rentrer au journal vol qu'elle
était assez débutantes et lui avaient ce
contrat signé en 49 donc ils ont
commencé à faire
design de qualité on la mettait un petit
peu à tout
tous les sujets et ils sont entendus dès
le départ vraiment et là c'était une
telle complicité que ensuite quand il a
signé un deuxième contre 1 elle
l'accompagnait toujours il n'ya pas une
photo pouvait se faire sans qu'on soit
ensemble ça a certainement beaucoup pda
à son aisance dans ce milieu là parce
qu'il était effectivement accompagné de
nos complices absolue qui elles étaient
issus de ce milieu là et qui donc
elle avait les codes étaient
parfaitement à l'aise et pouvait
certainement le chemin compagne et les
bains donc c'est il est probable que ça
a beaucoup ajouté dans cette dans cette
possibilité de
d'excellence du travail pour qu'on peut
montrer aujourd'hui vous avez retrouvé
ses photos alors comment vous est venue
l'idée de créer cette exposition et
notamment ici à l'espace richaud de
versailles comment ça vous est venue
cette départ c'était pas le projet
n'était pas sur l'exposition il était
sur un livre un livre qui commençait à
se faire peu à peu et finalement ce
livre devait sortir un petit peu plus
tard mais quand il ya du projet
d'exposition qui s'est greffé sur ce
sujet là pour fait que les deux en même
temps
l'expo est jolie devait vraiment être
pieds et justement alors un livre qui
sortira donc l'exposition commence
mercredi 8 mars est un livre également
sort mercredi 8 mars alors peut-être
france est ce qu on pouvait sentir un
petit peu plus sur ce livre
alors le livre c'est l'exposition avec
beaucoup bongo de photos puisque un a300
en touffe
mais c'est vrai que quand on nous on a
visité l'espace richaud on s'est dit que
cette lettre merveilleux dans cet
endroit si beau voilà de montrer les
photos de bâle 2-2 d'architecturé qui
étaient proches de cet endroit là aussi
mais une personne nous a bien aidés pour
se poser d'exposition c'est laurent
fontaine qui est la scénographe de cette
exposition parce que dans un lieu pareil
il faut quand même avoir des idées pour
l'accrocher à la sin city voilà un
dernier mot sur l'exposition on aime est
ce que vous vous avez une ou des photos
des thématiques qui vous parlent le plus
qui vous touche le plus c'est difficile
elles sont toutes fonctionnelles surtout
c'est votre père en plus ça vous
rappelle des souvenirs pour envoyer ses
photos
oui bon on connaît certaines on a
découvert c'est vrai en faisant de
livres que certaines avec des photos
avaient été faites pour vol par exemple
patti et son vélo mois jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je ne savais pas qu'on avait
été commandé pour votre blog et vous des
photos qui vous ont plus marquer
peut-être le mot jeu on est dans la
salle kim que j'adore parce que c'est la
vie du spectacle et je pense que mon
père était un homme de spectacle moi
c'est aussi le spectacle qui me fait
toujours bat le coeur et donc
que ce soit des jarres jeunes en train
de répéter le sacre du printemps ou
cocteau en train de diriger mon temps en
plein tournage d' orphée que ce soit la
beauté de fugitives de suzanne flon
comme ça dans un clair obscur ou où les
où la famille du chant c'est une photo
que je trouve absolument extraordinaire
où il ya tout d'un coup jacques villon
marcel duchamp et leur soeur suzanne du
champ qui était peintre aussi bien sûr
que ça c'est des témoignages absolument
magnifique
c'est un travail peu connue aussi de
votre père également c'est beaucoup
moins connue et la scène sont connus
quand même pas la totalité de ce qui est
exposé et dans le livre il y en a encore
davantage très bien m'a écouté bien
merci beaucoup à tout les deux annette
et francine en tirons le rappelle
l'exposition est à visiter jusqu'au 28
mai à l'espace richaud de versailles
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
jeudi bonne soirée à tous sur tv fil 78
[Musique]